Jennifer Lawrence is engaged really a
wedding dress the 28 year old actress
has worn Bridal Couture on screen and
now she'll be wearing it in real life
I'm Phil Roth I big mouth
et has learned Jay laws bow cook Maroney
has popped the question is here as we're
heating up the actress started dating
the art gallery director last year a
source spotted them enjoying a romantic
dinner in New York City where they
appeared super cuddly and very
affectionate and how's this for friendly
exes j-law brought cook to her former
flame Nicholas Holt's movie premiere in
September before cook Jennifer dated her
mother director Darren Aronofsky working
with your partner Darren collaborating
on this what makes him so great he's I
mean his his point of view is his
artistic
uniqueness he's just brilliant he's
incredibly instinctual Jayla always
candid opened up about why she's on good
terms with all of her exes in February
2018 she told the WTF podcast quote I
think it's because I'm blunt I don't
think that you can have any sort of bad
relationship with anybody if you're just
blunt there's no lying
it's just honesty all my boyfriends have
been wonderful
[Music]